Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Bonjour, willkommen and benvenuto to The Rest is History. Now, as you can tell by that beautiful European introduction, we have reached, in our World Cup marathon, the great and neutral country of Switzerland, haven't we, Tom? We have. Yes, we have. Very exciting.
感谢收听《历史的 restis》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Bonjour、wilkommen 和 benvenuto，欢迎来到《历史的 restis》。正如你从那段优美的欧洲语言开场白中所听到的那样，在我们的世界杯马拉松之旅中，我们来到了伟大而中立的瑞士，对吧，汤姆？确实如此。是的，我们来了。非常令人兴奋。
Are you going to be talking cheese, cuckoo clocks, alpine delights? What have we got to look forward to? No, I'm opening with a scene of execution. And it's the 27th of September, Dominic, 1553. Okay. And I'll give you the scene. It's a man who is preserving a grim silence. He's being led out to a location on the borders of the city of Geneva. He's being chained to a stake
你们是要谈论奶酪、布谷鸟钟、阿尔卑斯山的美景吗？我们有哪些内容可以期待？不，我将以一个行刑的场景开场。那是1553年9月27日，多米尼克。好的。我来给你描述这个场景。这是一个保持着严峻沉默的男子。他被带到了日内瓦城边界的一个地方。他被锁在火刑柱上
at the place of execution. And the pyre is a great pile of this man's books. Oh my word. So imagine that. I mean mean every author's worst nightmare yeah not only you being burnt to death but your books are being burnt as well that would be awful that would be awful and his execution is they've got the straw they've got these leaves they've sprinkled it with sulfur and they scatter it on his head and then they tie his arms behind his back make sure that he absolutely can't escape and then they light uh the fire and they show it to him he maintains his silence and then they set
行刑的地点。而引火柴则是这个男人的厚厚一叠书。我的天啊。想象一下吧。我是说，这是每个作家的终极噩梦，不仅你被活活烧死，连你的书也被烧掉，这太可怕了，太可怕了，他的行刑队准备了稻草，准备了树叶，他们在上面撒了硫磺，然后把它们撒在他的头上，接着把他的双手反绑在背后，确保他绝对无法逃脱，然后他们点燃了火，并让他看着，他保持着沉默，然后他们点燃了
the books alight and the flames start to crackle and flicker and it licks and touches the uh the unfortunate man who's been chained to the stake and suddenly he he screams and howls and for half an hour he suffers in agony and his very last words before he dies oh jesus son of the eternal god have pity on me wow tom it's like one of my um talks to primary schools this it's very gory but that's how i like it oh i see i thought you were comparing your treatment at the hand of the primary school children well there is that there is that element they generally burn the books after i've left right so you may be wondering who who is this yeah who is this man okay so he's a spaniard uh miguel cervetto but he's better known to us in the English-speaking world as Michael Servetus. He was a celebrated polymath, Dominic.
书本，火焰开始噼啪作响、闪烁，舔舐并触碰着那个被锁在火刑柱上的不幸男子，突然他尖叫并号叫起来，在痛苦中煎熬了半小时，他在临死前的最后一句话是，“哦，耶稣，永生神的儿子，怜悯我吧！”哇，汤姆，这就像我对小学作的演讲一样，太血腥了，但我就喜欢这样。哦，我明白了，我还以为你在拿你受小学生虐待的经历作比较呢。嗯，确实有那么一点，确实有那么点因素。他们通常在我离开后才烧书，对吧。所以你可能在想，这是谁，这究竟是谁？好吧，他是个西班牙人，名叫米格尔·塞尔维托（Miguel Serveto），但在英语世界里，我们更熟悉的名字是迈克尔·塞尔维特（Michael Servetus）。多米尼克，他是一位著名的全才。
Okay, yeah. And actually, he's very keen on science. You'll be glad to know. Oh, no. So he's the first European to describe the circulation of the blood. He's lost a lot of sympathy in the Sandbrook household already, Tom. So as you'll know, that's an achievement that's usually chalked up to the Englishman William Harvey. But sadly, I'm afraid the Spaniard got there first which is very sad it's the americas all over again
好吧，是的。实际上，他对科学非常热衷。你一定会高兴的。哦，不。所以他是第一个描述血液循环的欧洲人。汤姆，他在桑德布鲁克（Sandbrook）家庭里的好感度已经全败光了。正如你所知，这通常被归功于英国人威廉·哈维（William Harvey）。但遗憾的是，我恐怕这位西班牙人抢先了一步，这太让人难过了，这简直是美洲大陆事件的重演。
so civetus is also he's a great cartographer loves his maps he's a brilliant linguist he can speak all the ancient languages so greek latin um hebrew interestingly his french isn't actually very good uh and in Geneva, they speak French, and this is going to be part of the story. But the reason that he is a controversial and celebrated figure in Europe, and the reason that he has been chained to this stake and is being burnt alive is the fact that he is probably Europe's most controversial theologian. He's from Aragon. He'd been a page boy in the train of Charles V, the emperor who's king of Spain as well. And that takes him to Rome. He sees a lot of the workings of the Roman church and it appalls him.
所以塞维图斯也是一位伟大的制图师，热爱地图，他是一位杰出的语言学家，会说所有古代语言，比如希腊语、拉丁语、希伯来语。有趣的是，其实他的法语说得并不好。而在日内瓦，人们说法语，这将成为故事的一部分。但他在欧洲成为一个充满争议且名声大噪的人物的原因，以及他被锁在火刑柱上并被活活烧死的原因是，他可能是欧洲最具争议的神学家。他来自阿拉贡。他曾是查理五世（Charles V）随从中的一名侍童，查理五世是兼任西班牙国王的皇帝。这带他去了罗马。他看到了罗马教会运作的许多黑幕，这让他感到震惊。
He's disgusted by the display of the papacy's corruption. And the backdrop to this is the emergence of Luther, the start of the Reformation, and he becomes a very, very committed reformer, becomes a very committed Protestant. But he pushes the trends of radicalism and Protestantism to very, very radical extremes. So he denies original sin, which is the doctrine that since the fall of man, the whole earth is fallen, that all of us human beings are born with the taint of original sin. But also, perhaps even more controversially, he denies the doctrine of the Trinity, which ever since the age of Constantine has been fundamental to how Orthodox Christianity defines itself. This idea that God is three distinct persons sharing the one essence. And he denies this, which is why his last words,
他被罗马教廷腐败的作风恶心到了。而这一切的背景是路德的崛起，宗教改革的开始，他成了一个非常非常坚定的改革者，成了一个坚定的新教徒。但他把激进主义和新教的倾向推向了非常非常激进的极端。所以他否认原罪，也就是这样一个教条：自从人类堕落以来，整个世界都堕落了，我们所有人出生时都带有原罪的污点。但不仅如此，或许更具争议的是，他否认了三位一体的教义，自君士坦丁时代以来，这一直是正统基督教定义自身的基础。这种观点认为，上帝是三个不同的位格，共享同一个本质。他否认这一点，这就是为什么他临终前的遗言，
and you remember, Dominic, he refers to Jesus as being son of the eternal God, is so key because he's not describing Jesus as the eternal son of God. So he is implying that Jesus is inferior to God the Father. And that's unacceptable. And this is why he is suffering the fate he is, because fire is the penalty for heresy. And this is generally associated with the Catholic attempt to repress heresy. So you think famously of the Inquisition and in the English context,
你还记得吗，多米尼克，他称耶稣为永生神的儿子，这非常关键，因为他并没有将耶稣描述为上帝永恒的儿子。所以他是在暗示耶稣不如圣父上帝。这是不可接受的。这就是为什么他正在遭受这样的命运，因为火刑是异端的惩罚。这通常与天主教镇压异端的尝试联系在一起。所以你会想到著名的宗教裁判所，以及在英国的背景下，
the burning of Protestant martyrs at Smithfield. But what is distinctive about this is that it's not the Catholics who are burning this poor guy, Michael Servetus, but the Protestants. Geneva is perhaps actually the most famous Protestant city in the whole of Europe by the 1550s. And by and large, Protestants are reluctant to burn heretics because they themselves are viewed by the Catholics as heretics. And so they're much more kind of sensitive about that. But they don't rule it out. And this is because even the most kind of enthusiastic Protestants have come to recognize by the mid 16th century that it is possible to push the Reformation a bit too far. And the absolute kind of shining example of this, well, shining is the wrong word, the kind of the monstrous example of this is what happens in Munster in 1534-5. The whole doctrine of Protestantism is sola scriptura, the idea that if it's in scripture, then it's justified. And the Anabaptists kind of look in scripture.
在史密斯菲尔德烧死新教殉道者。但这次事件的独特性在于，烧死这个可怜的家伙——迈克尔·塞尔维特的，不是天主教徒，而是新教徒。到16世纪50年代，日内瓦或许已经是整个欧洲最著名的异教新教城市了。总的来说，新教徒很不情愿烧死异端，因为他们自己就被天主教徒视为异端。因此，他们对这种事要敏感得多。但他们并不排除这种可能。这是因为，甚至连最狂热的新教徒到16世纪中叶也开始认识到，把宗教改革推得太远是有可能的。而这方面的绝对光辉典范——呃，光辉这个词用得不对，这方面的怪物级典范，就是1534至1535年在明斯特发生的事情。新教的整个教条是“唯独圣经”（sola scriptura），即如果圣经里有，那就是正当的。而再洗礼派就在圣经中寻找依据。
They find that biblical patriarchs have had lots of wives. They've instituted communism. They've gone around smashing images. And so this is what they do. So the Anabaptists rule in Munster. There's polygamy, there's wholesale desecration of images and icons and everything, and basically communism. And the scandal and the horror of this reverberates across Europe, in Protestant Europe, as well as in Catholic Europe. And Anabaptist Munster ends up being stormed by an alliance of Catholics and Lutherans. So essentially, this whole kind of episode channels for Protestants the kind of the paradox that haunts the Reformation, which is basically, how do you fashion an order that permits Protestants the liberty that will enable them to worship in the way that they feel God wants them to worship. But at the same time, maintaining sufficient discipline that this
他们发现圣经里的先知们有很多妻子。他们实行了共产主义。他们到处砸毁偶像。所以他们就是这么做的。因此，再洗礼派统治了明斯特。那里有一夫多妻制，有对偶像和圣像的大规模亵渎，还有基本上是共产主义的体制。这件事的丑闻和恐怖在整个欧洲回响，无论是在新教欧洲还是天主教欧洲。明斯特的再洗礼派最终被天主教徒和路德派的联盟攻陷。所以从本质上讲，这整个事件为新教徒展现了困扰宗教改革的悖论，也就是：你如何建立一个既能赋予新教徒自由、使他们能够按照他们认为上帝希望他们的方式进行崇拜的秩序？同时又能保持足够的纪律，以确保这种
liberty can then be kept secure. So how can you have freedom of worship, but ensure that it won't kind of collapse into this bloody, sexually depraved horror show of which Munster is the shining example. And the reason that Geneva by the 1550s has become as famous as it has done is that it seems to Protestants to offer the transcendent answer. So Geneva has become the great arc of the Reformation. It's the place where Protestants can go to preserve themselves from the storms and the floodwaters of persecution that are starting to wash over Europe. So for instance, reformers go to Geneva from both England and Scotland, because the forces of Catholic
自由能够得到保障。那么，你如何既能拥有信仰自由，又能确保它不会崩溃成为像明斯特那样血腥的、性堕落的恐怖秀呢？到了16世纪50年代，日内瓦之所以变得如此著名，是因为它似乎为新教徒提供了一个超越性的答案。因此，日内瓦已成为宗教改革的伟大方舟。它是新教徒为了保护自己免受开始席卷欧洲的迫害风暴和洪流侵袭而可以前往的地方。例如，英国和苏格兰的改革者都前往日内瓦，因为那里的天主教
reaction are very strong there. So Queen Mary has come in, she's starting her persecution. So English reformers are heading there. Likewise, in Scotland, John Knox, who will go on to become the kind of the figurehead of the Scottish Reformation, he turns up in Geneva. And he describes it as famously as the most perfect school of Christ that ever was in earth since the days of the apostles. So Geneva, at this point, is it a republic? Is it part of the Swiss Confederacy? Yeah, it's a city-state. It's a city-state. So Switzerland consists of a number of city-states, a bit like kind of ancient Greece or Renaissance Italy. And lots of them are great enthusiasts for the Reformation. But each city has a slightly different understanding of what the Reformation should be. And Geneva had not been kind of preeminent in this to begin with. It was Zurich, it was Basel,
反动势力非常强大。玛丽女王上台了，她开始了迫害。因此英国改革者正朝着那里进发。同样，在苏格兰，约翰·诺克斯（John Knox）日后将成为苏格兰宗教改革的化身，他也来到了日内瓦。他将其著名地描述为“自从使徒时代以来大地上存在过的最完美的基督学校”。那么日内瓦，在当时是一个共和国吗？它是瑞士联邦的一部分吗？是的，它是一个城邦。它是一个城邦。所以瑞士由许多城邦组成，有点像古希腊或文艺复兴时期的意大利。它们当中有很多是宗教改革的狂热支持者。但每个城市对宗教改革应该是什么样有着略有不同的理解。起初，日内瓦在这方面并不是最突出的。那是苏黎世，是巴塞尔，
but Geneva comes up on the outside track and becomes this kind of shining example for Protestants of what a Christian community should be. But this is due to the leadership, not of someone from Geneva, not even someone who's Swiss, but a Frenchman. And that Frenchman, he's born in 1509 in Paris, takes the name Jean Calvin. But of course, he's best known in the English speaking world as John Calvin. Yeah. And that reflects the fact that his influence on Britain, on England and Scotland, and then by extension on the United States is absolutely huge. I would say it's impossible it's impossible to contemplate anglo-american culture
但日内瓦从外道赶上，成为了新教徒心目中基督徒社区应有模样的光辉典范。但这要归功于一位领导人，他不是日内瓦人，甚至不是瑞士人，而是一个法国人。那个法国人于1509年出生在巴黎，取名让·加尔文（Jean Calvin）。但当然，他在英语世界里最广为人知的名字是约翰·加尔文（John Calvin）。是的。这反映了一个事实，即他对英国、英格兰和苏格兰，进而对美国的影响是绝对巨大的。我认为，如果不提及约翰·加尔文，简直是无法想象盎格鲁-美利坚文化的，
without reference to john calvin his influence is that enormous and i think we should do a kind of an episode on him and his influence because it's a huge topic of course but just to sort of put it into really really simplistic terms for people like me who who are not you know devotees of theological history yeah calvin believes that there are two kinds of people, doesn't he? The saved and the damned. He does. Well, yes, and most Protestants think that. But Calvin is peculiarly rigorous in his kind of understanding
他的影响就是如此之大。我认为我们应该为他以及他的影响做一期节目，因为这是一个巨大的话题。当然，为了用极其极其简单的方式向像我这样的人——也就是那些并非神学历史狂热爱好者的人——解释清楚，是的，加尔文认为世界上有两种人，对吧？得救的和被诅咒的。他是这么认为的。嗯，是的，大多数新教徒都这么认为。但加尔文对这一观点的神学含义的理解有着异乎寻常的严苛。
of the theological implications of this. So he's a very, very smart guy, very, very clever, schooled in law in Paris, would undoubtedly have gone on to become a kind of leading figure in the French court had he not become Protestant at a time where this renders him liable to violent persecution. And so he flees Paris, he frees France altogether, and he goes over the border into Switzerland, and he tries out kind of various cities to see which seemed to him the most promising in terms of setting up a godly republic, but also which will offer him a sanctuary.
所以他是一个非常非常聪明的人，极其聪颖，在巴黎受过法律教育，如果他没有在那个因信仰新教而使自己面临暴力迫害的时期成为新教徒的话，他无疑会成为法国宫廷的领军人物。因此，他逃离了巴黎，彻底逃离了法国，越过边境进入瑞士，并在不同的城市物色，看哪一个在建立虔诚共和国方面最有希望，同时也哪个能为他提供庇护所。
And so he tries various places. He goes to Zurich, he goes to Bern, he goes outside Switzerland, goes to Strasbourg. All of these are kind of leading Protestant cities. But he ends up in Geneva and he has two cracks at staying in Geneva. So he goes there in 1538 and he piles in and he tries to mold it into a godly community. And this does not go down well. The Genevans don't want a Frenchman turning up and telling them they can't do things. So he gets run out of town. But three years later, Geneva is in such a rundown state. Its government is inefficient. It seems to be in a state of absolute moral decline, that the city elders decide that they will invite Calvin back. And Calvin is very clear that he will only come back basically if he has the kind of the run of the city. So he says, if you desire to have me as your pastor, then you will have to correct the disorder of your lives. And the city elders give him carte blanche to do this. And Calvin absolutely seizes his opportunity.
于是他尝试了不同的地方。他去了苏黎世，去了伯尔尼，还去了瑞士之外的斯特拉斯堡。这些都是领先的新教城市。但他最终来到了日内瓦，并在日内瓦尝试了两次常驻。所以他在1538年去了那里，一头扎进去，试图把它塑造一个虔诚的社区。这并没有受到好评。日内瓦人不想让一个法国人跑来告诉他们什么能做什么不能做。所以他被赶出了城。但三年后，日内瓦的状况变得如此糟糕。它的政府效率低下，似乎处于绝对的道德沦丧状态，以至于城市长老们决定邀请加尔文回来。而加尔文明确表示，他回来基本上必须有一个前提，那就是他要在城里拥有话语权。所以他说：“如果你希望我做你们的牧师，那么你们就必须纠正你们生活的混乱。”而城市长老们给了他全权处理此事的全权证书。加尔文绝对抓住了这个机会。
And what's striking about him is that he does not impose a dictatorship. So this is not even equivalent to say Cromwell's protectorate. Calvin does not have any civic office. And in fact, until 1559, he doesn't even have Genevan citizenship. He lives unarmed. He doesn't have bodyguards. The of geneva are free to insult him you know if they spit at him in the street he just turns the other cheek his only weapon dominic yeah is his pulpit oh the reason that the pulpit is such a kind of key stage for him is both because he's a brilliant speaker but also because he has thought through this great question of how Christian liberty, which he very highly prizes, freedom of thought, freedom of
而关于他，最引人注目的是他并没有实施独裁。所以这甚至不等同于克伦威尔的护国公政体。加尔文没有任何公民职务。事实上，直到1559年，他甚至连日内瓦公民身份都没有。他过着不带武器的生活。他没有保镖。日内瓦的居民可以自由地侮辱他，你知道的，如果在街上向他吐口水，他只会转过另一侧脸。多米尼克，他唯一的武器，
conscience, all that kind of thing, how it can be squared with the necessary order that affirms the fact that this is indeed a Christian commonwealth. So in his understanding of how Christians should lead their lives and what a church should be, he sets an absolute premium on the freedom of every individual Christian to join and to leave a godly community. That's nice. The dictates of conscience are very, very important to him. But what he also appreciates drawing on the lessons of scripture and the theological inheritance of the Christian church is that not everyone can be saved. And this is what you were alluding to, this idea that there are two kinds of people. There are those who are doomed to be damned and those who are saved.
就是他的讲道台。哦，讲道台之所以对他来说是一个如此关键的舞台，不仅因为他是一个出色的演说者，还因为他深入思考了这样一个宏大的问题：基督教的自由——他非常珍视这种自由，包括思想自由、良心自由以及诸如此类的东西——如何能与必要的秩序相协调，而这种秩序确凿地表明这确实是一个基督教共同体。因此，在他对基督徒应如何生活以及教会应当是什么样子的理解中，他将每个个体基督徒加入并离开一个虔诚社群的自由置于绝对首要的地位。这很好。良心的指令对他来说非常非常重要。但他也认识到——借鉴了圣经的教训和基督教教会的神学遗产——并非所有人都能得救。这就是你刚才暗示的，关于有两种人的观点。那些注定要下地狱的人和那些得救的人。
And Calvin's assumption is that the number of elect is very few, very small, that most people are predestined to be damned. And he says this is a dreadful decree. It seems a dreadful decree, but he doesn't shrink from it. And it's precisely because he knows that humanity has fallen, that most people will spurn the gifts of the spirit, that he's so keen to kind of shape Geneva into a community that can exist in harmony with God's plans and thereby kind of attract the elect to Geneva so that the whole city will become a kind of a community of the elect and thereby serve as a beacon to the rest of Christendom and to the rest of the world. And so the way that he kind of achieves this balance between liberty and order is that he institutes four offices that enable Geneva to be run according to his understanding of what a godly community should be.
加尔文的假设是，选民的数量非常之少，极少，绝大多数人命中注定要下地狱。他说这是一个可怕的法令。这似乎是一个可怕的法令，但他并没有退缩。正因为他知道人性已经堕落，大多数人会拒绝圣灵的恩赐，所以他才如此热衷于将日内瓦塑造成为一个能够与上帝计划和谐共存的社群，并以此吸引选民来到日内瓦，让整座城市变成一个选民的社群，从而成为全基督教世界乃至全世界的灯塔。因此，他实现这种自由与秩序之间平衡的方式是设立了四个职位，使日内瓦能够按照他所理解的虔诚社群应有的方式运作。
So there are ministers who preach the word of God. He's a minister. That's his role. He has teachers to instruct the young. So that's very important. You know, get them young. He has deacons whose role is to meet the needs of the poor, the sick, the orphans, the widows, basically to provide charity. So this is essentially a welfare state within the fabric
所以有宣讲神之话语的牧师。他是一名牧师。这就是他的角色。他有教导青少年的老师。这非常重要。你知道的，要从小抓起。他有执事，其职责是满足穷人、病人、孤儿、寡妇的需求，基本上就是提供慈善。所以这本质上是日内瓦社会内部的一个福利国家。
of Geneva. And obviously this is very, very appealing. So this is one of the reasons why by and large people in Geneva are happy to go along with Calvin's regime. And then he has elders, church elders, Presbyters. So this is the origin of Presbyterianism. And these are basically kind of moral watchdogs whose job it is to make sure that the Genevans are behaving. So they're like those people in Iran who go around telling you to put a veil on. They're like people in Iran or they're like people on Twitter. People calling you out, Tom, holding you to account. Yeah, people calling you out. Exactly so. And I mean, obviously on Twitter, the eye
显然，这是非常非常吸引人的。所以这也是为什么日内瓦人总体上乐于接受加尔文统治的原因之一。然后他有长老，教会长老，也就是长老（Presbyters）。这就是长老制的起源。这些人基本上就是道德监督员，他们的工作是确保日内瓦人循规蹈矩。所以他们就像伊朗那些到处叫你戴上面纱的人。他们就像伊朗人，或者就像推特上的人。那些对你进行公开指责、追究你责任的人，汤姆。是的，那些公开指责你的人。完全正确。我的意思是，显然在推特上，道德多数派的眼睛
of the moral majority are permanently on you. In Geneva, you have the same thing. You have the sense that these moral guardians are perpetually watching you. And every Thursday, they meet. It's like an American university. It is. Well, so I was saying that the influence of Calvin on Anglo-America is huge. And I think that it is not a stretch to say that American universities, which were founded, you know harvard's founded by presbyterians that that the american universities absolutely bear the stamp of this kind of calvinist um this calvinist train of thought so presbyters and ministers meet every thursday and they form a group that a body that is called the consistory basically Basically, they draw up lists of people who have offended
永远盯着你。在日内瓦，你也有同样的感受。你会觉得这些道德卫士永远在注视着你。每周四，他们都会开会。这就像一美国大学。确实如此。嗯，所以刚才我说过，加尔文对盎格鲁-美利坚的影响是巨大的。而且我认为，说美国大学——你知道哈佛是由长老会创立的——美国大学绝对带有这种加尔文主义思维方式的烙印，这并不是夸大其词。所以长老和牧师每周四聚会，他们组成一个名为“consistory”（总监会）的机构，基本上
God's law. So you might have failed to attend a church service. You might have transgressed the Ten Commandments. You made a joke about Jeremy Corbyn. Who knows? Exactly that. You might have misgendered somebody, anything like that, that kind of thing. So basically, if you offend Calvin's understanding of what a godly community is, the summons will come. And it doesn't matter what your rank, you know, you have to answer it. You can be the wealthiest merchant in Geneva. You could hold an official office in the city. You could be a magistrate.
他们会开列出违反上帝律法的人的名单。你可能没有去参加宗教礼拜。你可能违反了十诫。你讲了一个关于杰里米·科尔宾的笑话。谁知道呢？完全是这样。你可能用错了别人的代词，诸如此类的事情，类似的事情。所以基本上，如果你触犯了加尔文对虔诚社群的理解，传票就会到来。无论你的地位如何，（你）都必须回应。你可以是日内瓦最富有的商人。你可以在城里担任公职。你可能是一名治安法官。
If you've done something wrong, you get called out. You have to go and answer for yourself. And basically, I mean, every year on average, about one in 15 citizens of Geneva are called up before the consistory. And so the question is, you know, is this oppressive or is it liberating? And there are people in Geneva who find it incredibly oppressive. I mean, and hate Calvin. And actually, by 1553, which is the year that Cervetus will be burned, there are quite a lot of people in the city government who are getting very, very resentful of it and who are quite hostile to Calvin. But equally, Geneva has become this kind of great beacon for Protestants across Europe. And it is absolutely a part of Calvin's doctrine. You should welcome refugees
如果你做错了什么，你就会被点名批评。你必须去为自己辩解。基本上，平均每年大约有十五分之一的日内瓦市民被传唤到总监会面前。所以问题是，这究竟是压迫性的还是解放性的？在日内瓦，确实有人觉得这极其压迫。我是说，并且痛恨加尔文。事实上，到1553年——也就是塞尔维特被烧死的同一年，市政府里有相当多的人对此越来越感到不满，并且对加尔文相当敌视。但同样，日内瓦已经成为全欧洲新教徒的一座伟大灯塔。而加尔文教义的一部分绝对是：无论难民来自何方，你都应该欢迎他们，他们甚至不必是新教徒，他们可以是天主教徒、犹太人、无论什么人，你都必须欢迎他们，你必须为他们提供庇护，所以这里……它已经从黑暗中被唤醒了，我们这么说吧。
wherever they come from and they don't even have to be protestant they could be catholic they could be jewish whatever you have to welcome them you have to give them sucker and so there is this it has been awakened from its darkness let's put it like that right it is in other words in a very real sense it's very woke it's the progenitor of that idea yeah people can be wakened from darkness that there are people outside in darkness but we have yet woken to the light and that they have to be condemned and they have to be reformed yeah i mean literally i wasn't meaning that jokingly i meant it absolutely seriously but but of course the different the difference the difference is that today i think
换句话说，在非常真实的意义上，它是非常“觉醒”（woke）的。它是那种思想的鼻祖——是的，人们可以从黑暗中被唤醒，外面还有处在黑暗中的人，但我们已经觉醒见到了光明，他们必须被谴责，他们必须被改造。是的，我是说字面意思，我不是在开玩笑，我是极其认真的。但是当然，区别在于，今天我认为原罪的教条已经被取消了。但对加尔文来说，这极其重要。我们所有人都堕落了。因此，没有人能够采取一种道德优越的姿态，自以为他们一定能得救。所以长老们、牧师们并不认为自己已经得救，或者他们觉得自己可能得救。他们知道，如果他们的行为不够虔诚，那么他们显然就没有得救。但即使他们的行为很虔诚，他们也不能确信自己已经得救。因此，他们不断地审视自己的灵魂，并将自己已被救赎并成为选民的一部分——即使是加尔文日内瓦最虔诚的长老也是如此。我认为正是这种在自由与秩序之间制造张力的因素。你知道的，它平衡得非常非常微妙，因为这里有良心的自由。有一种说你想说的话的自由。
that the doctrine of original sin has been cancelled. But to Calvin, it's incredibly important. We're all for everybody is fallen. And so therefore, no one can adopt a position of such moral superiority as to assume that they are definitely saved. So the presbyters, the ministers, they don't think they're saved or they think they might be. They know that if they're not behaving in a godly way, then they're clearly not saved. But even if they're behaving in a godly way, they can't be certain that they're saved. And so they're constantly looking into their souls and putting the fact that they have been redeemed and a part of the elect and say even the most godly of presbyters in Calvin's Geneva. And I think it's that that gives this kind of tension between liberty and order. You know, it's very, very finely balanced because there is liberty of conscience. There is kind of freedom to say what you want.
同样，也有秩序。正是这种张力，使得日内瓦的实验如此激进且具有影响力。那么，塞尔维特是怎么卷入这一切的呢？好吧，塞尔维特和加尔文之间的关系可以追溯到很久以前。所以塞尔维特，你知道的，他是一个激进的新教徒。加尔文是一个激进的新教徒。1534年，塞尔维特在巴黎，他写信给加尔文说：“我真的很想和你谈谈。”于是加尔文冒着一定风险，在约定时间去了巴黎，而塞尔维特却没有露面。显然，
Equally, there is order. And it's that tension that makes the Genevan experiment so radical and so influential. Now, how does Servetus fit into this? Well, relations between Servetus and Calvin go back a long way. So Servetus, you know, he's a radical Protestant. Calvin is a radical Protestant. In 1534, Servetus was in Paris and he wrote to Calvin and said, I'd really like to talk to you. So Calvin, at some risk to himself, goes to Paris at the appointed time and Servetus doesn't turn up. So obviously,
这让加尔文非常恼火，这是可以理解的，然后他们就没有见面。加尔文一直关注着塞尔维特的轨迹，因为塞尔维特是新教激进边缘地带的一个确切人物。而且他对塞尔维特所写的东西越来越感到震惊。三位一体以及诸如此类的东西。是的，还有原罪。我是说，塞尔维特对原罪教条的拒绝直击加尔文神学的核心。所以加尔文对此非常非常不赞成。或许加尔文本来会满足于忽视塞尔维特，但除了一个事实：塞尔维特对加尔文变得绝对痴迷。我认为原因在于，塞尔维特看到了日内瓦的纪律结构，并认为这基本上是一种
this really annoys Calvin, understandably, and they don't then meet. Calvin keeps track of Servetus's career because Servetus is a definite figure on the kind of the radical fringe of Protestantism. And he becomes increasingly appalled by what he sees Servetus as writing. The Trinity and all that stuff. Yeah, but also the original sin. I mean, Servetus' rejection of the doctrine of original sin strikes at the absolute heart of Calvin's theology. So Calvin is very, very disapproving of that. And perhaps Calvin would have been content to ignore Servetus, except for the fact that Servetus has become absolutely obsessed by Calvin. And I think the reason for that is that Servetus looks at the structures of discipline at Geneva and he sees this as basically being
天主教教皇作风。他把加尔文看作某种教皇，认为他正在以宗教裁判所实施纪律的方式来实施纪律。因此，这在两人之间产生了一种张力，最终在1553年塞尔维特出现在日内瓦这一彻头彻尾的灾难中达到顶峰。我意识到我一直在说个不停。我们还没有休息。所以也许我们应该在这里暂停一下。当我们回来时，我将解释塞尔维特是如何最终来到日内瓦并遭受他所遭受的命运的。
a papist. He sees Calvin as a kind of Pope, that he's imposing discipline in the way that the Inquisition imposed discipline. And so this generates a kind of tension between the two men that will culminate in what is basically the disaster of Servetus' appearance in Geneva in 1553. And I'm aware that I've been talking a lot. We haven't had a break. So perhaps we should pause here. And when we come back, I'll explain how it is that Servetus comes to end up in Geneva and then to suffer the fate that he suffers.
我们休息一下。审视你们自己的良心。如果你觉得自己是选民之一，请在休息后回来。如果你是受诅咒者之一，你们所有人都可以……我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家播客和抢先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 restis》。选民们的成员，被诅咒者的成员，我们今天齐聚在汤姆·霍兰德的讲道台前，
We'll take a break. Examine your consciences. If you feel that you are one of the elect, return after the break. If you're one of the damned, you can all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Members of the elect, members of the damned, we are united here before the pulpit of Tom Holland,
伟大的神学家、传道人、道德仲裁者。他正在带领我们走过这个故事，呃，你告诉我，汤姆，这将是“瑞士塔利班”。我认为这是一个极好的标题。你还在坚持这个标题，还是已经放弃了？我觉得这有点严厉。我其实觉得这有点严厉。我的意思是，这确实是个挺不错的标题。我认为我们在这里专门关注塞尔维特的处刑。好吧，也就是烧死塞尔维特，我们回来继续讲烧死塞尔维特。好吧，这是怎么回事呢？到了1550年，
great theologian, preacher, moral arbiter. And he is taking us through the story of, well, you told me, Tom, this was going to be the Swiss Taliban. I think that is an excellent title. Are you still sticking to that title or have you abandoned it? I think that's harsh. I actually think that's a bit harsh. I mean, it is quite a good title. I think we're focusing specifically on the execution of servetus uh here okay so the burning of servetus we're returning for that crack on burn servetus okay so how does it how does this come about so by 1550 um servetus is living in vienne which is a french city on the rhone just south of lyon yeah i've been i've been to Vienne, Tom. I've passed through it.
塞尔维特住在维埃纳（Vienne），这是罗讷河畔的一个法国城市，在里昂正南方。是的，我去过维埃纳，汤姆。我路过那里。
It's lovely. Yeah. And he's living there, obviously, under an assumed name, because France is very Catholic, Servetus is a notorious Protestant, and he's practicing as a doctor. And in 1553, early in 1553, he publishes a book called The Restoration of Christianity. And it's in this book, Dominic, that you'll be delighted to hear that he mentions his theory of the circulation of the blood. Delighted to hear that, Tom. And one of the reasons why this doesn't become generally known in the way that, say, in the 17th century, Harvey's discovery of this theory will be is that this is a book
那里很可爱。是的。他住在那里，显然是用化名，因为法国非常天主教化，而塞尔维特是一个臭名昭著的新教徒，他在那里当医生。在1553年，1553年初，他出版了一本书，名叫《基督教的复兴》。多米尼克，正是在这本书里，你一定会高兴地听到他提到了他关于血液循环的理论。很高兴听到这个，汤姆。为什么这本书没有像17世纪哈维发现这个理论那样广为人知的原因之一是，这是一本
that is profoundly and shockingly heretical. And from Calvin's point of view, what is appalling about it is that it directly attacks his doctrines. So his doctrines of the Trinity, his doctrines of predestination, all that kind of stuff. Calvin is a very, very distinguished theologian and Servetus is directly attacking him. And what Servetus does is he sends it to Geneva. He sends it to the town hall in Geneva, together with 30 letters that Servetus has written to Calvin over the course of the preceding years and that Calvin has ignored. And again, this is kind of quite Twitter behavior. It's calling someone out, basically, and it's kind of it's calling someone out basically and and it's it's trolling them it's trying to get yourself noticed calvin has been ignoring him right but by now calvin is
具有深刻且令人震惊的异端邪说色彩的书。从加尔文的角度来看，这本书令人发指的是它直接攻击了他的教义。所以关于三位一体的教义，关于预定论的教义，诸如此类。加尔文是一位非常非常杰出的神学家，而塞尔维特在直接攻击他。塞尔维特所做的是，他把它寄给了日内瓦。他把它寄给了日内瓦市政厅，连同塞尔维特在过去几年里写给加尔文的30封信，而加尔文一直置之不理。同样，这是一种相当“推特式”的行为。这基本上就是公开点名批评某人，基本上就是公开点名批评某人，而且是在钓鱼挑衅，试图引起别人的注意。加尔文一直不理他，但到这时，加尔文
is so furious by this behavior that he writes to the civic authorities in vien and says you've got a notorious heretic living among you he informs informs on him. He informs on him. Servetus gets arrested. He gets tried. He gets sentenced to death. But he then manages to escape. And he's from Savoy in northern Italy. And so he's aiming for Savoy, he says.
对这种行为愤怒到了极点，以至于他写信给维埃纳的市民当局，说你们中间住着一个臭名昭著的异端。他去告发了他。他告发了他。塞尔维特被捕了。他受审了。他被判处死刑。但他随后设法逃跑了。他来自意大利北部的萨伏伊。所以他说他的目标是萨伏伊，
Except that he goes to Savoy via Geneva. Why on earth would you go to the very place? Or is this part of the trolling, as you would put it? I think it is. And I think that it's a deliberate provocation that is shaped by Servetus' apocalyptic views, his feeling that the end of the world is coming, that the four horsemen are galloping across Europe and that the appearance of Antichrist imminent, it's Servetus' job to confront the man whom Servetus sees as the servant of Antichrist, namely Calvin, and that Servetus is deliberately courting martyrdom so that his fate will serve to
除了他是经由日内瓦去萨伏伊的。他为什么大老远跑到那个地方去？或者正如你所说，这也是钓鱼挑衅的一部分？我认为是的。而且我认为这是一种蓄意的挑衅，是由塞尔维特的末世论观点塑造的，他觉得世界末日即将来临，四骑士正在欧洲大地驰骋，敌基督的出现迫在眉睫，而塞尔维特的工作就是去对抗那个塞尔维特视为敌基督仆从的人，也就是加尔文，塞尔维特是在故意寻求殉道，以便他的命运能够
kind of emblazon his understanding of Calvin and the horrors of what's happening in Geneva. And so he arrives in Geneva and he's arrested because he is plainly a heretic. It's not Calvin who arrests him. Calvin doesn't have an official position. He's arrested by the city authorities. But pretty much everyone in Geneva feels that it's legitimate to try Servetus as a heretic because they have the example of the Anabaptists before them. They're terrified of the kind of poison that radical heresy can bring. And basically, Protestants and Catholics are agreed on this. So I guess, again, to kind of pursue the modern parallel, I think we are tempted to side with Servetus, who we see as the spokesman for free speech. But it's a bit like, I don't know, a Nazi or a white supremacist or someone turning up in a university and- Giving a provocative talk. talk yes i say an openly racist talk that i think that that that gives you some sense of the the horror that cervetis presence in geneva inspires yeah and the anxiety about what to do
颂扬他对加尔文的理解以及日内瓦正在发生的恐怖。于是他抵达了日内瓦，并因显然是个异端而被捕。逮捕他的不是加尔文。加尔文没有官方职务。他是被城市当局逮捕的。但日内瓦几乎所有人都觉得审判塞尔维特为异端是正当的，因为他们面前有再洗礼派的前车之鉴。他们对激进异端可能带来的毒害感到恐惧。基本上，新教徒和天主教徒在这点上达成了一致。所以我想，再次借用现代的平行对比，我觉得我们很倾向于站在塞尔维特一边，把他视为言论自由的代言人。但这有点像，我不知道，一个纳粹、一个白人至上主义者或其他什么人出现在大学里——发表挑衅性的演讲。演讲，是的，发表公开的种族主义演讲，我认为这能让你感受到塞尔维特出现在日内瓦所引发的恐怖，
about him so what calvin wants is for him to be arrested and to be sentenced to death and then for him to be pardoned that's what that's what he says he wants but because the whole situation is becoming increasingly awkward for him just quick question does servetus have followers tom he does have followers so he has a number of um i guess you could call them humanists so so people who are more like erasmus say than luther right people who are who are definitely sympathetic you know they are protestant they're hostile to the catholic church they would see protestantism as leading to a kind of the right to to question
以及对如何处理他的焦虑。加尔文希望的是他被捕并被判处死刑，然后被特赦。这就是他所说他想要的。但因为整个局势对他来说变得越来越尴尬，一个简短的问题，塞尔维特有追随者吗，汤姆？他确实有追随者。所以他有一些，呃，我想你可以称他们为人文主义者。所以这些人更像伊拉斯谟，而不是路德，对吧？那些明确表示同情的人，你知道的，他们是新教徒，敌视天主教教会，他们会将新教视为通往一种质疑权利的途径——
uh you know all kinds of received doctrines that's kind of skeptics yeah but these are generally intellectual so so he doesn't have any kind of movement calvin only wanted him to be to be to be pardoned didn't he yes but the whole situation is kind of excruciating for calvin firstly because uh he's been having a lot of bust-ups with the city authorities, people who have been fingered by the consistory and who are very resentful of this and who are keen to embarrass Calvin in any way that they can. And the other thing that's embarrassing is that Calvin gets an official letter of thanks from the Catholic authorities in Vienne for his role in arresting. So that's very mortifying as well.
你知道的，对各种既定教义的质疑。那有点像怀疑论者。是的，但这些通常是知识分子，所以他没有任何性质的运动。加尔文原本只希望他被特赦，不是吗？是的，但整个局面对于加尔文来说简直是煎熬。首先，因为他一直在与城市当局发生许多冲突，那些被总监会指名道姓并对此深感怨恨、急于在任何可能的地方让加尔文难堪的人。另一件令人尴尬的事是，加尔文收到了来自维埃纳天主教当局的官方感谢信，感谢他在逮捕行动中发挥的作用。所以这也非常丢脸。
And so basically, Calvin is kind of losing it more and more with Servetus and he kind of fulminates that there is no form of impiety, which this monster has not raked up as if from the infernal regions. And so as the months go by, he basically, he swings around
因此，基本上，加尔文对塞尔维特的失控越来越严重，他大发雷霆，称没有任何一种不虔诚是这个怪物不曾从地狱深渊中挖掘出来的。随着时间的推移，他基本上改变了主意，
and he decides that Servetus should be executed, but it should be done with a sword. So it should be done as mercifully as possible but that he should be executed meanwhile the city authorities have been consulting all the various other cities so zurich and so on yeah and they all basically agree that servitors should be should be executed calvin says look don't burn him because that is too reminiscent of what the Inquisition do. But the city authorities decide that they will burn him. And they do this, I think, primarily to embarrass Calvin. Servetus becomes a pawn in the arguments and the power play between
他决定应该处决塞尔维特，但应该用剑。所以应该尽可能仁慈地处决他，但他必须被处决。与此同时，城市当局一直在咨询所有其他城市，比如苏黎世等等。他们基本上都同意应该处决塞尔维特。加尔文说：“听着，不要烧死他，因为那太让人想起宗教裁判所的做法了。”但城市当局决定烧死他。他们这样做，我认为主要是为了让加尔文难堪。塞尔维特成为了加尔文与城市行政官中的敌人之间争论和权力博弈中的一枚棋子。于是消息传到塞尔维特那里，他将被烧死。加尔文描述了塞尔维特的反应。起先他惊呆了，然后叹了气，全房间的人都能听到。接着他像疯子一样呻吟，再也没有了恶魔附身者的镇定。最后，他的哭喊声越来越大，以至于他不断地捶击自己的胸膛，用西班牙语大叫：“怜悯，怜悯。”哦，所以在说了那么多殉道的话之后，塞尔维特在听到判决后，非常合理地心想：“天哪，我到底还是不想这样。”不，他坚持自己的原则。哦，他是的。是的，所以他要求在被烧死前见加尔文一面。
Calvin and his enemies in the city magistracy. And so the news is brought to Servetus that he's going to be burned. And Calvin describes Servetus's reaction. At first, he was stunned and then sighed so as to be heard throughout the whole room. Then he moaned like a madman and had no more composure than a demoniac. At length, his cries so increased that he continually beat his breast and bellowed in Spanish, mercy, mercy. Oh, so after all the martyrdom talk, Servetus, not unreasonably, when he's told the sentence, thinks, oh God, this isn't for me after all. No, he sticks to his principles. Oh, he does. Yeah, so he asks to see Calvin just before he's due to be burned.
加尔文去见了。加尔文试图说服他放弃异端邪说，这当然能救他免于一死。塞尔维特拒绝了。当塞尔维特被带往行刑地点时，加尔文的一位挚友和追随者陪着他，同样试图说服他放弃。但当然，塞尔维特没有。于是他被烧死了。当然，这对加尔文的名誉是一个沉重且持久的打击。因此，塞尔维特的朋友们，他的学者同伴们——我们刚刚谈论过的那群人——谴责他为新教皇、希律王、本丢·彼拉多。在1554年——也就是塞尔维特死后的第二年，出现了一本书，名为《论异端以及是否应该迫害他们》。
Calvin goes to see him. Calvin tries to persuade him to recant, which would, of course, have preserved him from death. Servetus refuses. As Servetus is being led to the place of execution, one of Calvin's closest friends and followers goes with him, again, trying to persuade him to recant. But of course, Servetus doesn't. And so he is burned. And this, of course, is a terrible and enduring blow to Calvin's reputation. And so Servetus's friends, his his fellow scholars the ones we were talking about they condemn him as as a new pope as a herod as a Pontius Pilate and in 1554 which is the year after Servetus's death a book appears which is called concerning heretics and whether they to
这些是摘自我们一直在讨论的那类改革者的著作的文本集合，也就是那些更具学术性的伊拉斯谟派（Erastian）改革者，他们在书中明确反对对异端处以死刑。他们说，这不应该做。这太天主教化了。这本书的前言是由塞尔维特的一位特定朋友撰写的，这个人名叫塞巴斯蒂安·卡斯特利奥（Sebastian Castelio），他也是加尔文的坚定反对者。他论点的核心在早期的现代时期和启蒙运动中产生了回响。他说，新教徒乃至基督徒之所以不应该迫害和处决异端，根本原因在于那是基督曾经遭遇过的。当然，这也是伏尔泰将要采纳的一个论点。这也是一个关于自由的论点。
be persecuted and these are a collection of texts from the writings of the kind of reformers we've been talking about the more scholarly Erastian reformers, in which they very explicitly oppose the death penalty of heretics. They say, this is not to be done. It's too papist. And the preface to this book is written by a particular friend of Servetus's, a man called Sebastian Castelio, who is also a great opponent of Calvin. And at the core of his argument is one that will reverberate into the early modern period and into the Enlightenment. And he says that the reason that Protestants and indeed Christians should not persecute and execute heretics is that basically that is what happened to Christ. And this, of course, is an argument that Voltaire will pick up. And it's an argument that free
受到迫害。这是一些我们一直在讨论的这类改革家著作的文集，即那些更具学者风范的埃拉斯托派改革家，他们在书中非常明确地反对处死异端。他们说，这不应该做。这太具有教皇派作风了。这本书的前言是由塞尔维特的一位密友塞巴斯蒂安·卡斯特利奥撰写的，他也是加尔文的坚定反对者。他论点的核心在近代早期和启蒙运动中产生了深远的回响。他说，新教徒乃至基督徒之所以不应该迫害和处死异端，主要是因为基督就是这样遭遇的。当然，伏尔泰也会接受这个论点。这也是一个关于自由的论点
thinkers who are opposed to Christianity will pick up. They will say, you know, we're not against Christ, but we're against the framework of religion. And you can see here- The career of Philip Pullman. Well, you can see the way in which the Reformation is the womb, both of the distinctive quality of religiosity, which will mark American culture, but also that strain of a free thinking emphasis on tolerance, the ambivalences, the paradoxes, which will mark the history of modern Europe and modern America. That's why I think Calvin's Geneva is so fascinating. I was about to say, it's a tension not just in the reaction to the execution of Michael Servetus, but it's also a tension that's implicit in the structure of Calvin's Geneva, isn't it? Order and liberty, as you said. It is. And the influence of Calvin's Geneva on the Dutch Republic, on England, on Scotland, on the English colonies in America, it is impossible to emphasize how huge the influence is. Right.
反对基督教的思想家们会反驳。他们会说，你知道，我们不是反对基督，而是反对宗教的框架。你在这里可以看到——菲利普·普尔曼的职业生涯。你可以看到，宗教改革是美国文化特有的宗教情怀的温床，但也是那种对宽容的自由思想强调、充满矛盾和悖论的根源，这些将塑造现代欧洲和现代美利坚的历史。这就是为什么我认为加尔文的日内瓦如此迷人。我正想说，这不仅是对处决米歇尔·塞尔维特反应中的一种张力，而且也是加尔文日内瓦结构中隐含的一种张力，不是吗？正如你所说，秩序与自由。确实如此。加尔文的日内瓦对荷兰共和国、对英格兰、对苏格兰、对英属美洲殖民地的影响，这种影响之巨大怎么强调都不为过。没错。
And that's why I mean this incident is absolutely fascinating. I think for the light that it sheds on the way that our culture manifests itself right at the moment. Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. You know, I think that we attempted to side with Servetus, but Calvin is really wrestling with issues that we are still wrestling with at the moment. Right. You know, we believe in freedom of speech don't we in debate and all these things we don't believe in total freedom as long as you don't say the wrong thing and then we don't believe in it um and that wrong thing might be racist it might be xenophobic it might be exactly whatever and the question of of you know how how total should the limits of free speech be what limits
这就是为什么我认为这件事绝对迷人。我认为它照亮了我们文化目前显现自身的方式。是的，绝对如此。你知道，我认为我们试图站在塞尔维特一边，但加尔文实际上在努力应对我们今天仍在努力应对的问题。没错。你知道，我们相信言论自由，对吧，在辩论中以及所有这些事情上，我们并不相信绝对自由，只要你没说错话，然后我们就不相信了，嗯，而那句错话可能是种族主义的，可能是仇外心理的，可能恰好是什么别的，而关于言论自由的界限应该有多绝对，这些界限
should be set on them are obviously incredibly live issues. Of course. Yeah, absolutely. So just for people who don't know, what happened to Calvin and Calvin's Geneva in very, very simplistic terms? So Calvin stayed in Geneva. He's still the boss, basically. Yeah, he dies. Yeah, he's the boss. And Geneva retains its very, very Protestant character. I mean, right the way up to the present day, there's a kind of great series of statues of the reformers from the age of Calvin and so on, Reformation statues. Calvin is, yeah, I mean, he maintains his hold on Geneva and on the imaginings of Protestant Europe. But isn't it weird though, Tom? I mean, Switzerland is one of those places that you just think the sense of a sort of an abyss between history and present is so vast.
应该设定在哪里，显然是极其热门的话题。当然。是的，绝对如此。所以对于那些不知道的人来说，加尔文和加尔文的日内瓦究竟发生了什么，用非常非常简单的话来说？所以加尔文留在了日内瓦。基本上他还是老大。是的，他去世了。是的，他是老大。日内瓦保留了其非常非常鲜明的清教徒色彩。我的意思是，一直到今天，都有从加尔文时代开始的一系列伟大的改革家雕像等等，宗教改革雕像。加尔文，是的，我的意思是，他对日内瓦以及新教欧洲的想象保持着控制。但这不是很奇怪吗，汤姆？我的意思是，瑞士就是那种让你觉得历史与现实之间的深渊如此广阔的地方。
I mean, history is kind of exciting book burnings and indeed people burnings. And present is banks and people enjoying apres-ski. The contrast could not be greater. Calvin presumably would be pretty gutted if he went to Switzerland now. But there is a kind of, there's a sobriety about Swiss culture. Yes, I suppose so. I mean, it's not like it's famed for its wild hedonism.
我的意思是，历史有点像令人兴奋的烧书活动，甚至是烧人活动。而现在则是银行和享受滑雪后休闲的人们。对比再强烈不过了。加尔文如果现在去瑞士，大概会感到非常沮丧。但瑞士文化确实有一种清醒。是的，我想是的。我的意思是，它又不是以疯狂的享乐主义闻名。
No, no, you're right. So I think it does preserve that kind of slight Calvinist character. Yeah. And if some Swiss bank would like to sponsor us to do a tour of Geneva, we might be able to bring ourselves to do that. Do you think, Tom? Yeah, I think so. That's such a fascinating story, Tom, because it's both completely, like so many great stories,
不，不，你说得对。所以我觉得它确实保留了那种微微的加尔文主义色彩。是的。如果某个瑞士银行愿意赞助我们去日内瓦旅游，我们也许能说服自己去一趟。你觉得呢，汤姆？是的，我想是的。这是一个如此迷人的故事，汤姆，因为它既完全像许多伟大的故事一样，
it's both completely of its time and only comprehensible within the context of its time. But it also anticipates so many of the issues in contemporary culture. Yeah, it does. And I think that, I mean, we taught right at the beginning of this World Cup extravaganza when we were doing our episodes on the actual World Cup itself. Yeah. And I said at the start of the first episode that there are two areas of historical inquiry that lots of people who, you know, may be fascinated by history, but are proud to say they don't care about one of them being sport, but the other one is religion. Yes. And there's kind of feeling that, oh, we don't want to touch theology because it's complex and boring.
既完全属于它的时代，也只有在其时代的背景下才能被理解。但它也预示了当代文化中的许多问题。是的，确实如此。而且我认为，我的意思是，我们在这次世界杯狂欢的最开始，当我们制作关于世界杯本身的节目时，我们就谈到了这一点。是的。我在第一集的开头说过，有两类历史研究领域，很多人（他们可能对历史着迷，但很骄傲地说他们不在乎其中一个）一个是体育，但另一个是宗教。是的。而且有一种感觉，哦，我们不想碰神学，因为它又复杂又无聊。
But it really isn't. And it's so influential. Yeah. And we remain absolutely stamped by these theological arguments. And I hope that if you're absolutely gagging for more Calvinist theology, we will be revisiting the topic when we come to the Netherlands. Oh, yes. And we look at the ideology of the Dutch Republic in the 17th century. And also, Tom, you are itching.
但它真的不是。而且它太有影响力了。是的。而且我们身上依然深深烙印着这些神学争论。我希望如果你非常渴望更多的加尔文神学，当我们来到荷兰时，我们会重新审视这个话题。哦，是的。我们会审视17世纪荷兰共和国的意识形态。而且，汤姆，你已经迫不及待了。
I mean, you are itching to do something about the Reformation, aren't you? Yeah, I am. Since the beginning of this podcast, you every now and again, you'll say sort of this little voice goes up and says, the Reformation and the producers frown grimly and shake their heads. But I think you'll be able to win them over one day. I think you might win them over Tom within the next 12 months. And that really is something.
我的意思是，你一直渴望做一些关于宗教改革的事情，不是吗？是的，我是。自从这个播客开始以来，你每隔一段时间就会说，某种微弱的声音升起并说，宗教改革，而制片人们则严厉地皱眉并摇头。但我认为你总有一天能说服他们。汤姆，我想你在未来12个月内可能会说服他们。这确实是一件了不起的事。
Who knows? Well, that would be something to look forward to. Very good. Okay. Thank you, Tom. That was,
谁知道呢？好吧，那将是一件令人期待的事。很好。好的。谢谢你，汤姆。那是，
as they say, an absolute tour de force. Thank you. And on that bombshell, goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes,
正如他们所说，绝对是一次精彩绝伦的展示。谢谢。伴随着这个重磅消息，再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家节目、
early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com That's restishistorypod.com That's restishistorypod.com I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及抢先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。